joshua why do you love filmmaking
filmmaking for me is my way of exploring
the world I don't see myself as many
filmmakers will say as a storyteller I
see myself as an explorer and it's my
way of living living my exploration of
the most important questions that we
face as as human beings of all the
billions of people on this planet why do
you get to make these two amazing films
why do you think do you think you were
chosen you were at the right place the
right time oh I think I just you know
you know what one just finds oneself in
in in a situation and and and we're all
in situations that are of immense
mystery and complexity and and and moral
actually facing terrible moral
conundrums enormous problems and we just
I think everybody if they just if we
just stop and listen to our conscience
will find ways of responding in
important ways to the situations we face
and I think that's all I've done was I
just tried to ask what is the what can I
do now I found myself living with
survivors at 26 years old of a genocide
who they were so afraid that they
couldn't even talk about what happened
to them because the perpetrators were
still in power and I I felt it's as
though I'd wandered into Germany 40
years after the Holocaust only to find
the Nazis still in power I was asked by
the survivors in the human rights
community to pursue this and when they
and just actually to film the
perpetrators and then ultimately to make
these two films and I did because I felt
that's what was important and I think
everybody anybody who listens to what's
important will will will do the right
thing and sometimes it will lead to work
like this right now on both the look of
silence and the act of killing you use
very little stock footage I know with
the look of silence you had a like it
believe an NBC recount which seems so
innocent the way they described it it
was so like oh we've we did the right
thing oh great you're doing the right
thing by this but why use so little
historical footage you have so much in
the present that's right and in the act
of killing also
in the uncut version of the film the
so-called director's cut as it's
released here in the United States there
is also only one clip of archived
footage and it's it's interesting
because in it's clearly it's a permit
propaganda film and the clip chosen for
the look of silence is deliberately
chosen to mirror that it's also
propaganda masquerading as the news but
actually it's celibates an NBC clip that
celebrates a genocide and it's it's
import those two clips are important
because they're they reveal how lies art
I've been told to create this present
day context of total impunity and even
set open celebration of atrocity and the
reason why there's no other there's no
kind of more traditional use of
historical footage of archive footage is
because this is these films are not
about what happened in 1965 these films
are not historical documentaries about
the genocide these films are about
impunity today and the lies that are
told that that constitute that regime of
impunity how do you stay in the moment
filming interviews when your life is on
the line you just you take all the
precautions you can I suppose at the
beginning to before you get to that
moment of confrontation to so that you
know that that you have say a back-up
plan you have safety procedures in place
I don't think my life was ever on the
line while I was making either of my
films making the look of silence but you
do all that preparation you do your best
and then you try to forget about it in
the moment and you just try to be there
with the human beings you're filming in
part because if they feel you're seeing
them as human beings they that that that
makes the situation safe because they
recognize you're not seeing anybody
there as an enemy you're not you're that
they feel even if they they know that
there's a judgment about what it's
something they've done they have to
overcome they're disarmed by the fact
that you're that everyone present is
approaching them as as human beings was
there a scene with the look of silence
that got away was there something that
you almost had maybe you had your full
Danish crew with you with the set up
and unfortunately you had to cut it
short and leave there's it's actually
the film the final confrontation in the
film or Adi goes and visits this family
that was a very that was that in a sense
went totally out of control and wasn't
what we anticipated at all I had spent
three months working with that family
and the father in that family the death
squad leader father in that family to
dramatize what that father had done and
went and so it never we go and visit
this family and it never occurred to me
that the family would pretend they
didn't know what the father had done
because they would know because I would
know they're lying the whole idea there
was odd he would go and say I know you
you know me it's not your fault what
your father did and we have to live
together my daughter might one day want
to marry one of your sons and be
terrible if we can't come together for
them as a family and live together but
because they did know who he was they
lied and pretended they knew nothing and
they ended in this mess where I'm
confronting them with this old footage
essentially proving that they're lying
not because I'm trying to humiliate them
by catching them in a lie but because
i'm trying to get past that denial and
the Sun it they say how angry they are
at me they don't like me anymore the Sun
is actually calling the police when we
finished shooting that scene and we did
have to kind of run away it was a I I
thought I was very sad about I thought
we had nothing there I felt we'd gone
there to build bridges not to burn them
and I liked that family actually despite
despite the fact that they'd all
willingly participated in the
dramatization of atrocities I liked them
and I was sad about how this worked out
I then came to see though that this
scene more than maybe any other in the
film shows honestly how torn this
society is and how urgently Truth and
Reconciliation are needed were there
moments with audie where you felt that
you needed to rein him in because maybe
he was going too far I know he's he's so
like st. like in his film I mean he
shows no desire for revenge on his face
at least in his body language but were
there moments where you felt like you
know what audio you still have to live
here and work here and your family's
here maybe hold back a little not not as
not in the sense that Adi was ever
showing anger or a desire for revenge
with his neighbor's never but the whole
idea that we confront the perpetrators
came from oddee and my first response
was absolutely not we cannot do this
it's too dangerous there's never been a
film before this is the first
documentary film ever made we're
survivors confront perpetrators while
the perpetrators are still in power and
I only realized gradually that we could
do this because the production of my
first film the act of killing was well
known across the region and it hadn't
yet but the film had not yet premiered
it hadn't screamed so I was believed to
be close to the highest ranking
perpetrators in the country and the men
Adi wanted to confront were regionally
powerful but not nationally powerful and
they would not dare attack us or detain
us because they wouldn't want to offend
their superiors so in general Adi
throughout the process would be the one
proposing the most daring things
including my filming with the
perpetrators in the first place but
never did he never did he with what
would he be become aggressive and and
and and lead the situation to become
explosive that was never not who he is
and knowing that he's a gentle empathic
man was the kind of basis for my for my
agreeing to take these journeys with him
so it was only the initial request to do
this that you felt you needed to rein
back but then once you decided to go
ahead you were fine with it and then in
releasing the film Adi might have felt
safer than we have and we've we've taken
very serious precautions to ensure the
family safety Adi I suppose um it we've
had to advise him on risk because we're
more aware of the national level risks I
received threats from the highest
ranking perpetrators in Indonesia or at
least their henchmen still today Adi is
not not aware of that so I'm the person
who's monitoring and my team is
monitoring the risk and making sure that
audio mains safe